before getting into god's word
let's offer a prayer seeking his
instruction
father in heaven we're human your word
is divine
in the name of jesus christ their god
open our eyes to understand your word
we pray the words of david in psalm 119
verse 18 where he said
open thou mind eyes that i may behold
wondrous things out of thy law or out of
thy word
open our eyes to understand your word
bless us in every way i pray in jesus
name
amen in genesis 1 1 the bible says
in the beginning god created the heaven
and the earth now the rest of that
chapter gives us the details
of the creation on the first day of the
week god made light
on the second day he made the firmament
on the third day
he divided dry land from water and made
vegetation
on the fourth day sun moon and stars
on the fifth day the fish of the sea and
the fowls of the air
on the sixth day land animals and
mankind
then in verse 31 of chapter 1 here's
what the bible says
and god saw everything that he had made
and behold it was very good and the
evening
and the morning were the sixth day we
know from genesis 1
god took six days to create heaven and
earth
but we know a week has seven days and so
we go now to chapter two of genesis
we shall read from verse one thus the
heavens and the earth
were finished and all the host of them
let me read that again
by saying it differently everything god
had to do
he did in six days now
on the sixth day he made mankind meaning
that if we're made in his image
we must work the way god works we must
function the way god functions
listen again to verse 1 of genesis 2.
thus the heavens and the earth were
finished and on the seventh day
verse 2 of genesis 2 god ended his work
which he had made and he rested on the
seventh day from all his work
which he had made and god blessed the
seventh day
and sanctified it because that in it
he had rested from all his work which
god
created and made now in those two little
verses
genesis 2 and 3 we have tremendous
information regarding the seventh day
sabbath
let us see how often god identifies
which day is the sabbath and he does
that
before sin has entered the world listen
again verse 2
verse 3 of genesis 2 and on the seventh
day
god ended his work which he had made and
he rested
on the seventh day from all his work
which he had made
and god blessed the seventh day and
sanctified it now the word it refers to
the seventh day
because that in it again and pronoun
referring to the seventh day
so we have five references we have to
the seventh day
as the day to be observed as the sabbath
let's read the verses again and see what
else we're told verse 2
and on the seventh day god ended his
work
ended and rested are the same in that
context
and he rested from all his work on the
seventh day
we're told three times that god rested
or ended his work on the seventh day
and so in genesis 2 verses 2 and 3 we
have
the day identified and we have what god
did
he rested now god does not need to rest
spiritually
he rested however a god rests we are
told to rest
physically and to rest spiritually
so the fourth commandment says exodus 20
reading from verse 8
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
it does not say remember the sabbath day
to make it holy
only god can make something holy god
invites us to preserve something he has
made
we go to museums and we look at
beautiful paintings
and sculptures and they are preserved
some paintings
are preserved behind the glass the
climate is controlled
because the painting is fragile it is
preserved national parks
are places where things of value are
preserved
god says to us i am giving you a
treasure
i want you to preserve it remember the
sabbath day
keep it holy keep it in the condition
i made it and give it to you my
listening friends this
is a tremendous honor that god will ask
us to be the curators of his sabbath
the preservers of a masterpiece
the other six days cannot compare with
this day called the sabbath
and god has recruited us and continues
to recruit by the preaching of the word
people who are willing to work with him
in
preserving this masterpiece called the
sabbath
and so we read genesis 2 2 and 3 again
and on the seventh day god ended his
work which he had made
and he rested on the seventh day from
all his work which he had made
and god blessed the seventh day and
sanctified it
because that in it he had rested from
all his work
which god created and made i bring to
your attention
one more interesting fact in that small
passage
listen again genesis 2 2 and 3 and on
the seventh day
god ended his work which he had made
and he rested on the seventh day from
all his work
which he had made and god blessed the
seventh day
and sanctified it because that in it he
addressed it from all his work
which god created and made we're told
three times
it is his work which he admitted what
does that mean
creation is not only something god does
it is something god
alone can do creation is god's ability
and god's activity and every sabbath we
are to remember
that we serve a god who does for us what
no one else can do creation expresses
god's activity
and his ability and so i offer to you
genesis 2
verses 2 and 3 and on the seventh day
that day is special to god above all the
other sikhs
god ended his work we're made in the
image of god
let's end our work after six days unlike
our creator
let's rest god has called you to
preserve his day in the holy state in
which he made it
you can do that with the help of the
creator jesus christ
and so we read now exodus 20 8-11
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work
but the seventh day is the sabbath of
the lord thy god it's not mine
it's not yours it's the sabbath of the
lord thy god
if i loaned you my car you're taking
better care of my car than you do of
yours
because it is not yours the sabbath is
god's day
and we must be careful how we use it in
it
thou shalt not do any work thou not thy
son nor thy daughter
thy man's servant nor thy maidservant
nor thy cattle nor thy stranger that was
in thy gate
the commandment tells us to rest you
rest don't abuse yourself
it says your children must rest in some
countries
child labour is an essential part of the
economy your servants must rest
in some countries servants are
overworked your animals must rest
the sabbath recognizes the rights of
animals
the rights of workers the rights of
children it is a tremendous commandment
when we observe it
as it should be all of society is
blessed
not just you not just me but society
affected by my presence is blessed by
the observance of the sabbath
my children my family my workers whether
in my house or in my business office
my animals the sabbath recognizes the
right
of all levels of society i urge you my
friend
read genesis 2 2-3 read exodus 28-11
and you'll begin to understand why the
devil has attacked a commandment
that is such a blessing to society may
god bless you
and your family as you remember the
sabbath day to keep it
holy let us pray our father in heaven we
thank you for your love
your commandments are expressions of
your love
you have invited us in keeping the
sabbath holy
we are behaving as you behave grant us
power from above their god
through the indwelling spirit of christ
to observe your sabbath day
indeed all your commandments that the
life we live may reflect the very life
of christ
bless all the listeners their god in
jesus name i pray
amen